[Music]
Mad Max fury road this movie was
incredible
my name is critic and my world is Mad
Max as the internet went more batshit
crazy for fury road it was hard to tell
who was more betcha crazy me or everyone
else yes I am the one who runs from both
the fanboys and the haters I mean it's
good really good but is it the
masterpiece everyone praises hell I have
to be careful even just thinking that
can piss off some extreme fanboys out
there I just thought it was short on
story and not very practical it is not
above the logical necessity but the
excuse to display amazingly
action-packed possibly awesomeness we
even have a station running 24 hour bad
bags imagery so that the people can see
how superior fury road is
the best in my cave
drive worst braces ever just drive
says who my
treason betrayal underdog fanboys
[Music]
me here apply you never fully explained
silver crow this isn't chrome its cake
glaze oh what a Cleese what a lot boy
twice yeah that's one we're going with
blowing
[Music]
this time card he always had to wear
shit on his face yeah fucking beer in
road yeah what you didn't like it no I
did it was good action it was a great
rush why does that make a masterpiece
oh so you're one of those first two
films people actually I like Thunderdome
the best to Tina Turner's popularity
drop recently sorry but no one likes
Thunderdome the best is everybody's
hatred of Thunderdome we'll just sit
here until you take it back
what's your name curiosa curiosa aren't
you curious how I can like Thunderdome
more than the other films even fury road
just keep driving and I'll explain well
I'm deal boost the engine with some
intense fast motion stairs
okay so we know the Mad Max movies take
place in an apocalyptic future where
ex-cop max loses his family in fury road
he saves the abuse wives of a religious
dictator who controls on the water it
also gives us arguably some of the best
action in movie history right but does
incredible action and an adrenaline rush
equal a great film you do have a penis
don't you okay but 96% I'm rotten
tomatos great
Oh God 96% that's awesome yeah until you
realize that according to the critics
that technically means it's better than
Pulp Fiction
Fargo Jurassic Park Exorcist die hard
Hunt for Red October Terminator 2 and
every Indiana Jones movie really I think
people got so hyped up on the adrenaline
that they forgot it's just a simple
chase movie and what makes your precious
stuff though this video come because the
chase is only the climax the rest is
character story and unforgettable lives
we said the first two films did their
favorable 9b1 right now
I rode this road
it's very Road isn't visitors no quote
some lines from Thunderdome oh I know
raggedy man who runs Bartertown
master-blaster two men enter one man
leaves
exactly you remember it more because it
was more engaging it broke up the action
with good writing and twists and turns
it was just better storytelling hey just
because we don't have a lot of talking
doesn't mean we're not telling our story
we're telling our story through strong
visuals and through strong acting oh
come on the acting is good but tell me
what I'm thinking by just looking at my
stairs you're on a mission and you're
not gonna fit right and this one
you're afraid what's gonna happen to the
hoes just swore to protect you got it
and this one
they're gaining on us
no I was doing room or so I mean they're
together
what the hell is that oh that's weird
ass guitar guy no who is he where does
he come from
why is he have a blindfold on I don't
know I don't know and because he has so
much testosterone that his eyes shoot
shark-shaped exposures
okay that's exactly what I'm talking
about as fucking awesome as that is
nothing about it is explained who are
the people on the stilts in the swamp
what is the basis behind this crazy cult
religion who are the people he
hallucinates about his family people he
let die or are they just hallucinations
none of this has ever talked about it
doesn't need to be talked about
dinosaur missiles
so a lazy film gives you a blank page
something you've seen a million times
and film trying too hard gives you too
much so you can't make it out
fury road doesn't give you all the
information but it lets you see it for
what it is it allows you to become more
engaged because you can you connect all
the dots like how I'm not quite thing by
this fucking dinosaur missile flying at
me it just seems like something is crazy
a squirrel will create exactly just
because there's no details doesn't mean
there's no answers
speaking of answers how the hell is he
constantly missing whatever the hell we
believe in what is it's more enemies to
keep the energy hide fight that bad I
thought you loved that there minimus can
you believe they gave a gun to a chick
in this movie tell me about it
a man tweeting right now to let the
internet know my disgust that's the
manly thing to do they act like they're
being discriminated against when a woman
wants to do something that a man does we
have that it was called the 40s well
they're not very good at growing up well
it's got to be better than our other
friends here more meninist
no Tom Hardy fan girls
we're women who think Tom Hardy is the
second coming of Christ for some reason
really I mean he's a good actor but who
would go crazy over him probably someone
who spends their whole entire life
obsessing over fan bases punch wine I
mean - I found a new calling critic
converting everyone to the miracle of
Tom Hardy oh praise well I'm glad you
found something more sensible it's about
time the world saw an incredible tality
is and you don't think any of that stems
from mere physical attraction no no
since he's a feminist it would be
hypocritical to love him just for his
looks well Mark Ruffalo's a feminist
Patrick Stewart's a feminist
Louis CK's a feminist but Thomas dog ha
you know hurt is to find a man who likes
dogs whatever your attraction he can't
act like Tom Hardy's one of the best
things in this movie don't get me wrong
he does a fine job he does just as well
as Gibson but for his minimal dialogue
and mostly dubbed over lines they are
strangely more obvious than when he did
Bane he's serviceable at best which is
really all what Max is supposed to be
anyway but the work of his body I mean
the body of his work max is barely in
the film
he's been half the time in some broad to
all the fighting yeah so you're saying
what the rest of the world sees as the
manliest movie ever made you see as
being too girly it's a disgrace to
everything that Mad Max stands for yeah
well that's because there is a Mad Max
movie where he appears even less in it
and spends most of the time talking
about his feelings
really which one the original you
fucking moron in proportion of the
running time
Mad Max appears less on-screen in the
first film than he does in fury row he
doesn't even do anything that violent
until the final third on top of that
much like every George Miller film the
least interesting character is always
the main character it's the environment
that always takes center stage max is
merely the observer it's like saying you
wanted more Alice in Alice of Wonderland
it's just not how it works yeah but he's
working with a woman and even digging
orders from her and Max never does that
oh you mean like in Thunderdome when he
specifically goes to a woman saying I'm
looking for a job please give me orders
you actually liked Thunderdome look
imagine for a minute that Charlize
Theron Skerritt er wasn't a woman way
too close-minded well let's pretend that
you pretended max used to have friends
in the police force before he went rogue
so the idea of him being able to work
with someone again is actually kind of
uplifting for Max's character he spend
so much of the other movies just doing
everything alone that to finally find
someone to work by his side
you could argue gives a link back to his
humanity
actually brought something to the
character that's relatively new but that
doesn't coincide with the teachings of
our one true leader oh and who is your
one true leader Michael Bay the master
of action here and now critic as we all
know if you really wanted this to be a
manly movie you make it at least three
more hours long and the women should be
draped across the cars not driving them
that's like me showing female military
in the movie you all know it's never
gonna happen
and I can make out way too much what was
going on
clearly the car should have been
computer-generated instead of the
background you had it the other way
around I imagine you're driving while
those computer-generated cars now aren't
you well yes I do but why would you want
to know John robots
transform
oh dear now I'll never see the flower
show what was that I don't know if I
have a sudden need to compensate even
more
bring me the giant swingy stick second I
feel like our weaponry is to stick heavy
hey skeleton I think I figure out a way
to get out of my car along this memory
destroy the video of the critic and this
medial combine and I myself will carry
over to the premiere of the VEX
fatback's movie oh you'll need to do
that I just like
Loosli not equipped for the task at hand
they're too far gone I guess I shouldn't
have milk ben salomo shot but at least
it gave the audience a chance to catch
their breath
you could great back to the action oh my
god
are you telling or you like the manliest
man got a men yeah yeah oh yeah we're
men Ennis we stand up for our right to
be men hey now that's a cause I can get
behind
let's get over so what manly thing to do
you play football or you build muscle no
we make rent videos what I have two
YouTube subscribers of courses these
guys
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
so if bender domes your favorite which
one's your least favorite well I love
them all but laughs to answer the
question it used to be the first one but
now it's fury road it might be road
warrior wow those are the two that
people likes the most I mean the comment
section is already planning your death
but the fury roads credit it kind of
changed everything each movie had their
own distinct feel the first a low-budget
exploitation film Thunderdome low
survival flick and road warrior a chase
movie but the problem is fury road is a
chase movie too
they both focus on the action and stunts
rather than twists and turns in the
story because fury road is so much
better there's barely a reason to even
watch road warrior now it just feels
like a slower version of fury road but
it was the first one to give Mad Max its
style that is true Road Warrior is
considered by many to be the first real
Mad Max movie in that it takes place in
the desert and focuses more on the
action-packed loner the first one is a
revenge story and even then not until
the very end
story wise and stylistically it has the
least amount to do with the others
actually seeing as the movies are called
Mad Max and he never really seems that
mad maybe all the other movies are in
his head actually that kind of makes
sense
I wrote a fanfiction about that maybe he
went nuts after his wife and kid died in
many respects the film's do kind of keep
repeating themselves there's always a
tyrant there's always a group of people
he doesn't want to save but gets
shoehorned into doing so there's often
religious figures gang culture pigs an
old woman with a shotgun a wild kid or
kids and no places that look anything
like the first movie they even use the
same actors in different roles truth be
told it's actually not that bad a theory
great so does that mean you've accepted
Hardy as your one true max I'm sorry but
I still think Thunderdome is better oh
really
with all the other films you knew it was
gonna be in the first few minutes with
Thunderdome it kept you guessing it
changed up locations that threw in new
characters and it wasn't all one big
chase
but no was that I think impractical
Joe's and practically using is
impractical swinging sticks we walk the
red carpet children walk the red carpet
on
that's offense and that is surfboards
tonight
I'm not okay
wonder if the planet is having this much
fun and how dare George Miller have all
the male Penguins and happy feet stay
with the kids
yeah well all the women penguin did all
the hunting because that's what Penguins
Dow will they should change that women
ruin everything like in Mad Max so it's
us all you guys do you just sit around
complain how you hate hot women you want
Seymour shirtless buff man man yes are
you guys gay I'm a it's fine if you are
but you clearly got some anger issues
you know we're we're not anti-gay no no
no we're very fair in our hatred yeah
it's just women we hate hundreds of
years of advantage and we're not giving
it up now let's go watch pain and gain
that's a straight movie oh I do a
commentary on that let's turn the
mechanical claws of grogginess don't
right there's nobody left just me
I'm sorry but Puri Rove is just one big
chase and I can't see what's so
brilliant about that
my god I seem how I get it
I know why Puri road is a brilliant bill
you finally hit me I know now not only
why it's genius but as the most
ingenious out of all the bad backs
boobies why don't you see what this is
the don't you'll see what this all is
a roadrunner cartoon what are you
talking about so Roadrunner cartoons
have lasted for years with little to no
dialogue quickly identifiable characters
and nothing but chases people see it as
classic because it's so minimal and yet
so interesting it says so much with just
a few clever choices fury road is the
same way just because it's all one big
chase doesn't mean that isn't smart and
it doesn't mean that it's not a
game-changer as much as I love
Thunderdome there are a few scenes that
are kind of boring and I can skip but
with fury road
I can't imagine skipping any of it it's
all amazing to witness from the music to
the action to cutting out anything
that's simply not needed it gets right
to what people want to see and keeps
them there throughout the entire flick I
can hardly think of any other field that
did that throughout the entire thing
you're right you've always been right
fury road is the better flick I don't
think he wants to listen hang on
short turn
and that's my sandwich could have been a
man
[Music]
what do you do I have an idea
I can't see a thing with this on it I'm
just going to take it off
well that's something I didn't think I
would see today oh I forgot about
national insecurity they can't have a
woman do that you should have let that
critic do it yeah wait I know how to
show them the fuck up
stop the car everybody else go out there
let's trust me there meninist just go
out there boy we're gonna show that
wait you have actually talked to a woman
before right
you want to go out oh thank you not five
dots of these pussies one more time I
was gonna shoot my balls off thank God
you stopped we really needed to be break
Hey look Dibble Bo's on her side trainer
you ain't no man yeah and who are Christ
if you're the future what being a magnet
slap a fucking vagina baby
I might rather be a badass why card that
whiny little bitches like you
hey here's a thought if you have to
complain about how someone's stealing
your manhood chances are you've never
had your man hugs a bitch anyway what
are you fine you're ready gotta get
cooties and how's that working out for
you anyway
our women just falling at your feet
because you bitch and complain about of
my line real chick magnet guys you must
get laid a lot you know what Tim living
in your mama's basement because the
grown-ups are gonna make the more badass
world and we don't need your cry baby
tears poison it up are you single I
can't be and now a message from the
President of the United States
my fellow Americans in light of the
recent meninist movement all female
soldiers shall be immediately removed
because women shouldn't be fighters for
saving men really instead all female
soldiers are to be replaced with
meninist seeing us how they complain
that only men should do the fighting
there to take their place and be
deployed immediately
guess what guys I just got a new job
thus all female soldiers shall be
rewarded the Tom Hardy movie marathon as
we all know is a method actor so uh are
you a feminist and whatever you want me
to be
[Music]
it's over everyone's cheering because we
destroyed him practical Joe and all is
right in the world wait that's it he
didn't have any followers or anything
like that it's kind like the death star
once it's gone you don't really question
the logistics of it no well I've learned
what a phenomenal film fury road truly
is and that it has earned its place
rightfully in film history hey that
reminds me what is your name anyways
[Music]
critic
my name is critic
boy that wasn't as shocking as I thought
it was gonna be yeah it's the title I
don't know why we thought that would be
such a big deal well why don't you just
end things in a typical fury road way oh
you mean with a visual that seems half
dance but it's actually badass yep
[Music]
we will walk the red carpet sugar the
glazed
hey everybody Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out sadly I don't have any
video for you this time but I do have
pictures and I'm even in a few of them
and speaking of which do you like comics
or manga if you're watching me you
probably do this charity is actually for
the Carolina manga library this is a
traveling charity that tries to raise
awareness and teach literacy through
mangas and comic books they travel from
Kanaka they travel from school to school
they do all sorts of various events and
pretty much the idea is to teach you
reading through manga and comic books
because a lot of people don't see that
as reading and of course it is you can
also get some wonderful artwork you can
find out new ways of discovering
storytelling and this very much is
allowing people adults and kids alike to
find a place where they can read some of
their favorite stories donate books if
you would like and help spread awareness
that reading is important everyone needs
to do it and it only makes you smarter
and more creative they have access to
tons and tons of comics and mangas
remember those old Zelda comics from
Nintendo Power yeah they got those they
got the Avatar comics they have tons
from Japan they have a tough American
ones as well the list just keeps going
if you have a couple of bucks to spend a
couple of comics to give or even just
want to spread the word that literacy is
important definitely drop by this
address and check them out
[Music]